[Music]
i challenge you to not skip that
i have never
scratcher oh yeah but you will this is
how we're gonna do this i'm gonna show
funny strata haha videos okay jack is
gonna try not to laugh and then we're
gonna do the exact same thing on jack's
channel same challenge and whoever
laughs the least
we'll go to the grand finale they'll
call it five for the next round they'll
go to uh that final round where they can
win 10 million dollars
6 billion
hosted by mr beast i'm just saying okay
this is going to be so awkward of me
just sitting here not laughing
and then you're wondering if discord's
even working or
i have color coordinated my videos
what thinking will he laugh at this and
this is an orange so it could go either
way are you ready oh no i thought you
meant that the colors in the videos were
all coordinated with each other now some
high level i'm i'm not a
psychopath okay
okay i have i have seen this video
but i only watched it once
i just love these videos where
you read the title and you're like
that's not gonna happen right
he did the thing he farted um dogs
didn't run away oh my god
i
i knew it was coming
that's the thing you really tied up when
i watched it with evelyn we were kind of
like talking through it and then it
happened was like oh ha ha but now
hearing it isolate it on its own
hey i get to left this is great yeah i
[ __ ] hate this that's why i thought
it was orange because you've seen it i
feel like yeah you haven't seen him it
would have been a good chance you made a
scrat thing how many times do i have to
tell you
nordvpn.com
slash pewdiepie
i won't say who did it but someone i
know downloaded nordvpn paid for nordvpn
without using the link there's no code
use link you want to be safe online
use a vpn you want to be free online use
a vpn you want to be epic online use the
goddamn con
anytime i travel or doing my dirty
business online you got to protect
yourself otherwise your isp will know
exactly what you're doing otherwise
other people spying on your wi-fi know
exactly what you're doing you don't want
things people knowing what you're doing
do you i know that you don't want to do
that and i won't say anything don't
worry as long as you use the goddamn
link use the link because
for every purchase of a two-year plan
which you should get we'll get you one
additional month free baby and
okay
brace squeeze your butt as hard as you
can surprise gift i see the clicks
coming in now you're all clicking on the
link i knew it they got some great deals
on nordvpn in february oh the additional
month free
is available on youtube only they are
celebrating their 10 year anniversary
happy birthday in the vpn that's awesome
new subscribers will get either one
month one year or two years on top of
discount plus one free month that's a
that's very generous you can watch
popular movies on netflix that are not
available in other countries
as a strong proponent for free and open
internet i highly recommend using a vpn
trust me you can try it out they have a
money back guarantee you will find use
out of it and if not then i will look
like a fool but yeah that's it congrats
northvpn on your 10 year anniversary
thank you for sponsoring yet another
video fantastic sponsor you guys have
been uh
giving good feedback appreciate on with
video i feel like you're going to bust
out some really weird feelings on me you
you have some like really weird like
deep lore videos that's that's cyber
that's not me i i have nothing to do
with without you seem to have like a
reaction picture every time anybody
sends you anything on whatsapp and
they're all different all the time
i take my reaction gifts very seriously
all right
scary easter bunny i think we've seen
this one together no am i that stupid i
need brain surgery jack are you sorry
don't don't worry i do the exact same
thing all the time
okay
[Applause]
they start off so excited
oh my god have we seen this am i that
out of it
i just love seeing them they don't know
how to their parents do nothing yeah so
they don't know what to do they just
like run around
i think the parents did this completely
on purpose to terrify their children
okay i think it's fine that you didn't
laugh at that because
i'm gonna hit you with this one oh no it
was all a ruse
why did you poke the frog
but it's just
oh
traumatized for life
for life why would you do that you
flicked it that way
i see i want to laugh now is it is it
okay for me to laugh after
[Laughter]
that's terrifying ah it makes me ill
that poor child
traumatized forever
they wanna you know you go around the
park and you see a kid who's like
there's dogs running around the kid's
like the highest on the monkey bars and
they're terrified and they don't want to
go anywhere in yours how can you be
afraid of a dog they're so nice and then
yeah it's because of the [ __ ]
because of stuff like that yeah yeah
they were chased up a tree when they
were six
[Laughter]
the poor kid look at the drip game
though look at those cord shorts he's
got the slippers on with the wrong foot
what an idiot he deserved what came from
him
good luck heading into college idiot
can't even put on shoes stupid chad all
right that's enough let's have children
stuff for now i see that that's not
working on you chad are they all orange
what you don't like
those were green unfortunately those
were my trap cards oh
i'm doing well yeah
you don't like watching chill and stuff
for jack what are you so i'm sorry
absolutely
i just take my competition very
seriously okay
well what about this
here you go rocky i know how much you
like wieners
i know how much you like wieners
i'm so sh
what do you mean it's hilarious this is
what i mean this is some like
i'm laughing because i know it makes you
laugh
i know this is the [ __ ] that you watch
on your spare time and you giggle to
yourself and that's what's making me
laugh yeah these all made me laugh come
on
oh yes
outside count it ding it
bang it put it on the board save let's
go i own it nice
this is uh orange again so could go
either way you never know
i have spanish one and spanish too
but this is the word i do remember from
it this is the word that i remember from
spanish
and this what it is
boom
you listen your song
i know you want to i know you want to
you're not getting me no
that buildup though that guy knows how
to tell the story he does
it kind of caught me off guard i thought
it would say like magusta or something
but well it's in the title oh
[Music]
not delicioso
it's the it's the opposite of the the
horse farting one where it's like that's
the title and you're like come on prove
it you're a tough component component
yeah you're a tough component i'm a
tough competitor yeah
that's what my my parents used to always
say when i was a kid
uh jack i have a question for you uh-huh
what's the skeleton's favorite snack oh
i don't know you don't know take a guess
i have a joke for you
what
what is a skeleton's favorite snack
go on guess
death
no come on gas
booms
gas that's what i thought too why are
you laughing i haven't told the
punchline yet come on it's obvious what
is it dad's favorite snack
gas
gas
why won't you answer me
what is my favorite snack
no
no run
what is it
why must you fail me so often
i think he's yelling
[Applause]
you know what the worst part is yeah
i've seen this and i couldn't
remember what the answer was ribs all i
could remember was that he says bones
ah so good damn it
jack playing with tom holly i gotta
check that out
yeah
save that watch later what that's cute
i'm not like mark is a strong boy you
should say that to your queue as well
yeah yeah
right after you watch the fun time
freddy compilation uh
what is happening what's my youtube
algorithm
i gotta be honest with you jack all the
clips i showed you already
have been decoys trapped they've been
trapped they've not been set up to make
you laugh i know you're a tough
component jack but nothing's gonna make
you laugh that's what they say
like this
gregory do you see a small vent on the
floor
have you ever heard of among us gregory
you need to be you need to defend i know
it will be hard
[Music]
no it ain't doing it no the guy doing
the voice thinks he's funnier than he is
okay okay okay okay that was also a
decoy watch this
[Applause]
no
no
your biggest weakness jack
no god
[Applause]
so stupid
[Applause]
why
it's not even funny
i'm sorry i apologize everyone every
time there's a fart joke the longer it
goes on the funnier it gets yes
i hate it i i hate it more than it makes
me laugh i hate that that's my trigger
i apologize
i'm seven years old that was unfair
that's like going to war with a nuke
that blasted me from orbit with that one
i don't feel proud of that one either i
gotta be honest with you i had to just i
had to get it out of there damn it you
know
two baby let's go i do anything to win
just like you're trying really hard so
am i jack i have to pull out my golden
card oh god those cheeks everyone's
going to judge this framing sense of
humor now but i guess that shouldn't be
no sense
for 10 years
have you seen this one it doesn't look
familiar okay
[Applause]
funny indian rally co driver
[Applause]
medium left
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
a good friend
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
offloading in this race fine jesus
[Applause]
anyone driving with their wife in their
car can relate to this wow
that's what we're going with
i'm joking uh i don't drive a car i
don't stand with this okay all right i
don't stand with pewdiepie i don't
either [ __ ] him
[Laughter]
no all right that's a funny clip but
yeah that's okay how about this i don't
know awesome
[Music]
i mean i'm not either i'm happy about
that okay good i'm just taking advantage
of the country
but i'm not assimilating to society i
don't know why i watched that and it
just made me laugh i don't know why
yeah i have problems okay all right all
right all right how am i doing all right
you're not ready for this am i halfway
through yet i'm not
ready for this you better squeeze hard
for this one jack okay this is my asian
doll baby here we go
no you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up you
glitched it
this is like getting waterboarded
you know that torture where you have
like the drip on your head and you're
tied up and it's just drip drip drip for
hours and hours and you go crazy yeah
exactly that's what this is yeah yeah i
this is exactly like real torture guys
oh god i wrote that and played for and
see how long it takes for jack to laugh
but i guess
oh god i already i already hit you with
the fnaf one i didn't think that would
work okay
this will really prove if you and i have
bad sense of humor jay
are you ready this one yeah
this one
21st century humor in
176 seconds
[Music]
[Music]
you
is happening
i can't even keep up with the memes
[Music]
simon is editing right now just dying
having a heart attack i should have
saved this for hours damn it
you made it i don't understand this
humor this is where like the generation
snaps farting don't stop pretending that
you're better than anyone okay
oh my god i suck so what did i get was
that two i think that was two yeah you
got it you got a couple of like
out of me yeah you got a couple of
exhales but that was harder that was
harder than i thought i thought i could
make you laugh okay i got one more one
more this one is actually not that funny
oh god me
[Music]
i watched this on stream because i was
uh uh i was like i might as well stream
watching through the videos to find out
and i watch this i'm like animation is
never funny i even said that this is no
way this is gonna make me laugh
because i have got you know when you
plow through videos and like there's no
way to shoot
i've seen it
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
yeah baby
stop
[Music]
wait we gotta laugh
that's three baby
let's go
is that from an anime or is it edited i
don't know i no i don't want the answer
no i know it's funny or not to know yeah
that was i didn't i didn't expect her to
go full bionicle on me
well jack it's been my pleasure to host
this you laugh you lose with you i guess
i lost well we don't know if i lost i
don't know if you're lost or not who won
check out both videos lincoln channel
i'm feeling good about my one
all right well we're gonna see we'll do
the outro like we always do on this
channel smash like subscribe maybe if
you want to do it and you could win
6 billion jack could pay you
i could it could come to your house
dresses
freddy
[Applause]